this morning in our school matters
series some education experts say
summer learning is more essential now
than ever and i believe it a study
published in the american educational
research journal
looked at students in grades one through
six and found more than
half lost an average of 39 percent
of their school year gains during the
summer
a recent study found the most effective
form of summer education incorporates
fun
into the curriculum that's good news
joining us now is saul khan the founder
and ceo of the khan
academy uh saul good morning to you
always love having you on
the complication for this summer is of
course the pandemic so you've got the
loss
of the pandemic plus what we anticipate
being a loss this summer
can we begin to talk at this point do we
know what the learning loss has been
overall for this
12 months of pandemic time we've put in
some of the assessment partners that we
had talked to last
fall had already seen a 10 larger drop
than you normally see so you normally
see about a quarter of
of the previous year as being summer
learning loss that was last summer
then you had 10 on top of that we all
know we've had a strange year this past
year and then you're going to have a
learning loss on top of that
so by any measure this is going to be a
pretty tough year for a lot of
a lot of families so you also say that
summer school is
out or at least the term is and you
favor summer learning instead what's the
difference
well summer school has the stigma that
we all remember that if you didn't do so
well in that school year you had to stay
over the summer and maybe repeat a year
it was almost like
summer detention so it has all sorts of
negative associations with it
and the whole point is to just keep on
learning and summer school sometimes
makes you just repeat a lot of things
that you might already know
and so summer learning is for everyone
and now we have more tools than ever
obviously
my day job uh the not-for-profit khan
academy
people can get free resources they can
get free tutoring another not-for-profit
schoolhouse.world
there's tons of resources out there if
people put in even 20 30 minutes a day
there's no reason why they can't fill in
any unfinished learning that they have
from the previous few years
and even catch up or move ahead of where
their class is going khan academy is
incredible it's good for adults as well
if you want to tutor your children you
take a look at it then you can be more
helpful i i
totally recommend it but a lot of
teachers
and i know because i'm married to one
are feeling pretty burned out and a lot
of kids are feeling burned out after
zoom learning over the last year how do
you get people in
so many people just want to break from
all of this how do you get people in the
mood to do that
yeah i definitely wouldn't recommend
going all in and doing eight hours of
academic stuff
all summer people need to have a healthy
summer they've been socially isolated
for a year year and a half they need to
go out there need to play they have to
rebuild their social friendships
and also even when we go back to school
i know a lot of teachers i talk to
they're talking about those next those
first few months have to be about
rebuilding that social connections
rebuilding those patterns of school
making sure people are re-ready for
school again
but as a parent if your child can go in
with a strong academic foundation once
again the resources are out there we
have get ready for grade level courses
on khan academy
to fill in any gaps students might have
they're going to be that much better
prepared
come come the new school year i want to
follow up on anthony's thing about
listen how do you bring the joy make
sure that you say parents need to bring
the joy back
of summer for their children what's the
best way to do that
well it's all about play and there's not
a young person i know at ages four or
five who's not incredibly curious about
the world and there's no reason why play
and learning can't happen at the same
time
think about how far the sun is that you
could fit a million earths inside of the
sun
just that that sparks wonder that sparks
curiosity if
every time your child asks a question
say let's look that up let's see
let's see what the truth is there and
start going on a learning journey with
them and that provides really powerful
signaling for your children
all right sal khan always good to see
you thank you so much